[Music]
hey guys what's up welcome to D LM model
lifestyle I'm Daniel and in this video
we're gonna talk about modeling tips for
girls but I'm not a girl right so I
brought in someone that can share it a
little bit better I brought it in me I
brought in Maria thank you so much for
having me again is a pleasure to be in
your channel I am a huge fan of what
he's doing the work you're doing in your
channel is amazing because he's being
completely honest and really showing you
guys what's like behind the scene what
really goes on in the modeling world and
that's amazing so thank you for sharing
that thank you obvious converse so what
are you gonna do today
so today I'm very excited because I'm
gonna be sharing with you guys 15 tips
for modeling welcome good stuff very
juicy we did a video about modeling
poses I hope you guys saw it for women
forgive me a lot us that's not that one
but today is more about the work behind
the scenes what kind of behavior you
should have what are some tips on your
appearance how to present yourself for
clients or to the agency good stuff good
stuff okay do you want to buy a
hanger-on oh please do I want to find
like I want you to share from the male
perspective more of the same tips does
it change okay alright let's do it
let's get into that video
hey just before we start I just wanted
to mention that Maria started her own
YouTube channel alright so you guys can
check that out this especially for girls
or guys if you're curious
can you share what it's about sure I
share a lot of behind the scenes of my
shootings a little bit business a little
bit of healthy recipes something you can
do very easily on their own kitchen and
I would love for you guys to come and
check it out so you want to start yeah
so now let's get to it so modeling can
be the easiest job and the hardest job
at the same time
some days you're going to be shooting on
a tropical island with an amazing crew
and it's not even going to feel like
work you're gonna have so much fun
your Instagram is going to pop with a
lot of those very nice photos in other
days maybe a week after that you could
be shooting on below zero degrees
temperature in another Beach for other
we're cold freezing yeah yeah it's
talking from my own experience here it's
not fun guys not fun so good models they
know how to handle all the different
scenarios and challenges that come their
way
yeah so here are my tips to make you a
great model respect the clients product
do not make fun of that funny hat they
gave you or that weird jacket that's
impolite it doesn't matter if you're
working for Chanel or if you're working
for a brand that just started always
give your best a hundred percent yeah
guys look presentable when you go to
castings to the agency or for jobs yeah
I mean in Asia is very very important to
dress up but in countries like South
Africa or
Jeremy doesn't matter that much so you
can even go with a little bit of messy
hair because that's you you're unique
but still be neat and clean hair and
nails must be clean girls please before
you're shooting wash your hair have
clean nails don't get to the studio with
red nail colors that's a big no-no
that's the same for guys apart from that
the red nails I'm just meaning clean
nails and clean hair they extra
attention to your skin for a clear
complexion you should always drink lots
of water and scrub your face about two
times a week never never leave the house
without sunscreen and moisturizer that's
very important yeah that's just the
basic thanks for your skin yeah two
simple guys as well mix them young guys
they just feel like no it's not
important it's very important and I feel
some guys they feel moisturizers for
girls it's not just for guys as well we
don't need to have a good skin yeah
nowadays finally the industry realized
that consumers come in all shapes and
forms yeah yes but if you are a
high-fashion model you're probably gonna
have to fit in a certain measurement I'm
not gonna get into that now but I thank
anybody watching the girls do not get
into some crazy diets do not start
yourself that's not the way to go nobody
wants that the agency doesn't want that
after you the clients don't want that
from you the best thing you can do is
leave a healthy lifestyle forget the
word diet right yeah yeah yeah don't
don't even don't even think about it
just think about me healthy eating
natural products natural food leave the
process to stop the chocolate the
candies so be healthy be natural don't
focus on dieting a lot of people think
that models in tiny food and it's like
ah diet is not tasty but we eat very
very tasty food he stays healthy
so change to a healthy lifestyle
all right never change your hair or your
appearance without talking to the agency
first this is a must
yeah it's very very have you done that
before
it was younger gonna care funds big
mistake
yeah so chances are you already have a
job
booked if you cut your hair if you
change your appearance that's gonna be
trouble for everyone involved so we're
all speak up the phone call the agency
every two months when you go to your
hairdresser and ask can I cut my hair
it's two centimetres I'm changing my
style always always discussed with the
agency first yeah when you go to the
shootings
you must always wear new to color than
the word do not show off in the studio
is red white black none of that has to
be nude because if you're wearing
something see-through it's the only way
for it to work there's a lot of young
models they forget about that
my advice to you is as soon as you start
modeling go out go to the shopping mall
and buy a bunch because you're gonna
need them a lot yeah for guys do you
have to use nude underwear as well well
not really
what stick to white if you go to two job
starts better estranged because some
countries in Asia that ask you hey can
you bring nude color underwear and well
you don't really find that for guys very
hard so yeah that's the way yeah don't
forget to shave there's nothing more
ugly than eyeball the lifting her arm
and it's like hello not breathing not
pretty please change guys - no no we
don't we don't it depends on what type
of model you are but at least trim it a
little bit yeah I mean if you have a lot
of hair just a little bit if you're
shooting for jewelry chances are they're
gonna ask you to shave you our arms as
well because it doesn't look pretty if
you have jewelry
in here uh pretty close bracelet and
there's hair it's all over not pretty
I'm a hairy person I definitely have to
shave fortunately you know you have a
lot of hair in your head
chances are I'm a monk you forgot
sometimes as well I know this is weird
I don't election anything at all but
sometimes I have to shave my beard or
even on this contract here in South
Korea that asked me to shave my arm hair
a little bit another job I bet no no
even it's just a normal job no that's my
amends or of this for castings is better
if you wear tight-fitting clothes
although we love the oversized style is
not good for the clients because they
want to see your body shape so go with
tight fitting clothes for guys too
yeah same wears them fit clothes yeah it
works
go basic you don't need to go too crazy
but you leave the hoodies home
all right for beginner models please
don't try too hard to dress like a model
chances are that if you're making a
fashion statement
people are gonna judge you on that and
some clients they might not have the
same sense of style that you do so go
basic guys wear jeans by shirt by
cleaning again but don't try too hard
it doesn't look cool yeah if you don't
know what it's gonna work just wear like
black clothing that always wear black
clothing boom yeah all right guys this
one I got it from my mama if there's
anything you don't like about yourself
don't tell it to others because chances
are they never noticed but what too sad
that's the only thing they can see and
every time they see you they'll see
exactly that thing that's a good one
yeah yeah so when you work with clients
and studios especially agency as well
don't don't rise to your agency and say
I'm fat but then though we're gonna look
at your body or find where is the fact
yeah yeah and if you're insecure you
know if you wonder about how you look
and you're insecure and you mentioned
those things that you think is not
perfect chances are they're gonna think
you're not that confident and you are
insecure and clients want to work with
models who are confident all right I
would like to talk to you guys a little
bit about behavior looks they're gonna
get your jobs but behavior that's what
makes the client book you again and
again and you want that because hey more
jobs that's your goal yeah in any simple
surely you have at least five crew
members we're gonna have your director
or photographer yeah
[Music]
you better have your makeup artist this
hair stylist stylist in client yeah done
VDOT a good impression can make somebody
from the crew to refer you to the next
job yeah and that's always awesome when
it happens because you work with them
they saw the kind of work you did and
they like it and they're like I'm gonna
refer you to my next job yeah it is oh
it's so good to work with people you
know as a ninja I get to this shooting
I'm working with a makeup artist I know
or sometimes even the client you're so
much more free damnit they know a little
bit about your personality they know who
you are
it's I enjoyed that so much I lived for
those jobs being polite and respectful I
hope it goes without saying but here are
a few more tips that I want to share
with you guys be an act professional
arrive on time be present live whatever
is going on in your life outside when
you're shooting that's where your where
your attention should be yeah right
respect the makeup artists work do not
tell them I look better with a different
shadow alright I don't like the eyeliner
no girls please stay in your lane that's
very disrespectful
now another thing girls do I bet guys
don't do that but girls they'll go to
the bathroom - no try
picks it up yeah guys do the same thing
you do best that's not good guys if you
want them to respect your work you have
to respect their work as well
respect the hairstylist as well they
will make your hair look weird sometimes
it's it's just part of the job there's
nothing you can do and you have to
accept it and I think that's worst thing
for guys isn't it yeah does it totally
change if you change they hand out it
would completely change yeah you have
you look different yeah
this is my hairstyle I like it I love it
and then you get to the job and it's
just like oh but then I might even
suggest a little bit of something you
know but if I see that this is the style
I really want then I have to let it go
because that is being a professional
sure so when you get to the studio at
the makeup and hair table their problem
that I have in the mirror the concept of
that day's job right the client already
chose that he probably spent a lot of
time looking at photos and choosing what
you want so the makeup artist is a hair
stylist they have to follow that so
there's no saying I don't look good here
I don't look good there that's pointless
yeah the worst thing is I'd move some
guys when they come into the room and
they act like their own and everything
and not this is not how I wear my hair
don't be arrogant
nobody likes arrogant people right just
do your job because you're getting paid
for it
you're respectful beyond your
professional model so act professional
at some point somebody either photograph
or the client will ask you for a weird
pose yeah that happens a lot they were
asked you to bed a certain way that the
problem can't even do it so when they
say could you try this pose you should
reply yes I can try and then give an
honest shot if you got it great you
might even surprise yourself with this
you can do it that you didn't know and
if you didn't get it they're going to be
thankful because at least you tried
right yeah
a lot of photograph person will have a
screen for you to check your poses while
you're shooting so you're doing your
poses and there's a computer close to
you where you can see how it's looking
but in case they don't when the
photograph is stopped to check the light
or if the close is okay that's your
chance to go to this computer and check
how you're looking check your paws this
is everything okay anything that you
have to fix if you cannot see it on the
computer go and check the camera yeah I
just asked him a little bit especially
it at the beginning of the photo shoot
so you can get a clearer picture of how
you look like look the clothing with the
background so check it out
okay now you have a clear picture and
now you know how to pose better guys if
you're serious about modeling you should
definitely check Daniel's ebook down in
the description box below he talks about
modeling and he gives you a lot of good
good tips it's a must
yeah and hey don't forget to check out
our channel it is awesome go and
subscribe I'll see you guys there thank
you so much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed don't forget to give those big
thumbs out there guys
brilliant I see that all right now
oh that was close
alright alright alright alright alright
a lot of photographs there are ours the
industry realized industry they say was
a good thing that I didn't drink your
coffee never miss Bobby all right come
on my doing it again are true guys
before you over sorry sorry sorry